his day the squares and faces poisonous
puts a hand up and no problem for Davis
mix active defensively Jack throws it
away shot block from Davis comes running
down the floor and blocks the
three-point attempt
now with trade Berkeley name assigned
Davis pitched up low first thing is very
close to picking up his second foul from
the field
penetrating creating value
that was a shot clock turned off Knicks
have been in the penalty since early in
the period Holloway sit away then
Holliday gets it back throws it out to
Davis jack is on cousins David shoots
the shot knocks it down
those of Marv's call on the radio keep
Jackson did the honors on TV such a
versatile great announcer Davis gets
inside lays it up and in Davis now at 24
batboys Angus it'll be ad the other way
now exchanging buckets vases picked up a
little bit
Davis against O'Quinn Clark back to
Davis
this is good it comes more shut off
nicely by Courtney Lee cousins drops it
for Davis Davis pull off shot that's
good
[Music]
the porzingis biggest drives on Davis
first the chef gave us right there
expect trying to go
you'll get it porzingis is there he ties
it up 3.5 to play Leon holiday now they
isolate the youth footballs are out
there from porzingis Davis has to get it
out drives in a corner spins far away
extra
47 per Davis and the pelicans
by through